[Music]
and i've been taking care of
[Music]
care of business
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can be a
[Music]
[Music]
people see you having fun
tell them that you like it this way
it's the work that we afford we're all
self-employed
we love to work at nothing all day
and we've been taking care of business
everyday
taking care of business
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
every day
they get up every morning 8
15 into
[Music]
[Music]
and i've been taking care of
[Music]
care of business
[Music]
[Music]
taking care of business
taking care of business
taking care of business
care of business
taking care of business every day
taking care of business every way
taking care of business
[Music]
there
[Music]
do you remember when it first died
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my thoughts are with you holding hands
[Music]
remember today
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
another day
fill it up
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you lose the rhythm
[Music]
fractured
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it means everything
what are you waiting for
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
do it right
[Music]
right here now
right now
are you waiting for
[Music]
well i was born in a small town
[Music]
all my friends are small towns
my parents live in the same small town
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
vice president
and second lady of the united states
mike pence
and karen pence
[Music]
that she's still
[Music]
[Music]
is
maybe we can see things
all right now
baby's all right
[Music]
well baby michigan
[Applause]
man oh man do you all look great
are you ready
it is great to be with you all
congressman bergman congressman molinar
gop chair laura cox
john james
[Applause]
and all of you've been with us every
step of the way
it is great to be back in the great
lakes state
one more day to four more
[Applause]
years
that's what i'm talking about
thank you for that wonderful warm
welcome
he's going to be here in about 40
minutes
but would you all uh would you all join
me in just uh thank a few people first
and foremost
she's a marine corps mom she's been a
champion for military families
she's a school teacher at a little
christian school she's been my wife for
35 years would you join me in thanking
the greatest second lady
of the united states that we've ever had
my wife karen pat
thank you but karen and i are here for
one reason and one reason only
and that is that michigan and america
need four more years of president donald
trump in the white house
it's on michigan and the road to victory
goes right through the great lakes state
we need the people of this
freedom-loving state to do just what you
did in 2016.
by tomorrow night we need michigan to
show america
that this is trump country
but it really is great to be with you
all it really is great
also it's great to be here with some
good friends of mine and other
presidents
in fact one of whom is the highest
ranking combat veteran ever to serve in
the congress of the united states one
now he's one of the strongest voices for
our national events join me in thanking
congressman jack bergman will you
[Applause]
thank you jack it's also great to be
here with a man who has served the
people of michigan in the state
house and i've served alongside him and
i can tell you he is one of the
strongest allies of our president
and our agenda in the united states
congress congressman john mullinar
let me say what a privilege it is to be
here with a man that i got to know over
the last couple of years
he's a man of integrity he's a family
man
a west point graduate a combat veteran
a businessman and the next
senator from the great state of michigan
john james
well thank you all for being here i know
you're out today to
hear and see our president show your
support but i also know you're here
because of all that we accomplished
together over the last four years
i mean think about it four years ago we
inherited a military that was hollowed
out by devastating budget cuts
an economy struggling to break out of
the slowest recovery
since the great depression terrorism was
on the rise and we witnessed a steady
assault on our values
but in three short years we rebuilt our
military
we revived our economy we secured
our border supported law enforcement and
stood for life
liberty and the constitution of the
united states
you know after joe biden spent the
previous eight years
trying to tax and spend and bail our way
back to a growing economy
president donald trump created the
greatest economy in american history
and we're doing it again michigan
i mean how about those new gdp numbers
last week did you check that out
33 growth in the third quarter
shattered any previous record the great
american comeback is on
[Applause]
and with four more years of president
donald trump in the white house
we're going to bring this economy back
bigger and better than ever before
you know the president said it was the
biggest quarter in the history of our
country not
even close and he and i both know
this american comeback is a testament to
all of you
to the resilience and the strength and
the character of the american people
but it's also a tribute to a president
and our allies in congress
who created the greatest economy the
world has ever seen
that's why it's remarkable to think in
the midst of a global pandemic
joe biden wants to raise taxes by four
trillion dollars
his running mate kamala harris said on
friday
that their quote first order of business
would be to get
rid of president trump's tax cuts
they got a two trillion dollar green new
deal they want to put
socialized medicine in the heart of
obamacare
risk the health insurance of 180 million
americans
but under president donald trump in
three short years
we cut taxes across the board for
working families and businesses
we roll back more federal red tape than
any administration in history
we fought for free and fair trade
unleashed american energy
and businesses large and small created
seven million good paying jobs
including a hundred and twelve thousand
jobs right here in michigan
it's true
you know when joe biden was vice
president america actually lost 200 000
manufacturing jobs
it's amazing you know i come from south
of here in indiana
and just like michigan you know we do
two things well around here we make
things and we grow things
right we're proud of them
but the last president who i heard is
out campaigning today four years ago
he said those jobs were never coming
back
he actually said uh what magic wand do
you have
well we didn't need a magic wand we just
needed president donald trump in the
white house
500 000 manufacturing jobs
created in just three years
and when it comes to trade so important
to what we make and what we grow
joe biden's been a cheerleader for
communist china
all along the way and he never lifted a
finger to reform a trade deal with
mexico and canada that literally
cost thousands of factories to close
across this country
but under president trump we put china
on notice
we imposed tariffs and made it clear the
era of economic surrender
is over and nafta is gone and the usmca
is here to stay
you know um and joe biden's running mate
i actually
i had a debate with her in salt lake
city a couple of weeks ago
some people think we did all right so
thank you but i brought this up in the
debate
because you deserve to know kamala
harris was one of only 10
senators to vote against the usmca
she said it didn't go far enough on
climate change
i mean kamala harris put her radical
environmental agenda
ahead of michigan jobs and michigan
workers
and i'll make you a promise for four
more years
president trump will always put american
jobs and american workers first
[Applause]
and i'll tell you it's just as clear on
energy i mean joe biden
and kamala harris want to crush the
american economy
under a two trillion dollar version of
the green new deal
remember that first debate the president
had to remind joe biden that he
supported the green new deal
he does i mean the green new deal i'm
telling you
it would actually raise the cost of
electricity in your home and raise the
cost of electricity in every business in
michigan
president trump he's been a champion for
american energy we ended the war on coal
we've opened up our natural resources
and we're now a net exporter of energy
for the first time in 70 years
it's true but worse still
joe biden and kamala harris over the
last year said over and over again
that they want to abolish fossil fuels
and ban fracking
i mean that would cost hundreds of
thousands of direct jobs across the
heartland
they said it over and over again and
then joe biden shows up in pittsburgh i
wasn't far from there today
a couple of weeks back and he's trying
to convince people in pennsylvania that
he's not for bannon fracking he actually
said our president was lying about his
record
remember even in that presidential
debate and
how good did president trump do in that
presidential debate am i right
out of the park still going right
well in that presidential debate you saw
the moment where joe biden said that we
we needed to quote transition from the
oil industry
president trump said
said that's a big statement right
and then when the president called him
on it he said show the tape
so we've been showing the tape and i bet
when the president gets here he's going
to
show you the tape again
[Applause]
[Music]
men and women of michigan no matter what
joe biden and kamala are saying right
now you can take it to the bank
joe biden and the democratic party are
going to try and abolish fossil fuels
close down the oil industry ban fracking
but we're not going to let it happen
we're going to have more fracking more
american energy
more energy independence for this
generation and for generations to come
when we re-elect president donald trump
for four more years
i mean honestly here's the choice
america faces it's a choice between a
trump boom
and a biden depression i mean a study
just came out
nonpartisan study that said joe biden's
economic policy
would cost five million american jobs
and it would reduce the average income
of american families by 6
dollars a year so when you go home
tonight if you run into anybody tonight
or any time on election day
who hasn't made a decision yet in
michigan here's what you got to ask them
seriously just look at him and say who
do you
really think can bring this economy all
the way back
i mean a career politician who spent 47
years raising taxes
stifling the economy with regulation and
economic surrender
or a proven job creator who's overseeing
the fastest
economic recovery in history
to bring america all the way back we
need four
more years of president donald trump in
the white house
so it's about our economy but we all
know that security is the foundation of
our prosperity
and i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president who cares so
deeply about the men and women of our
armed forces
and their families
you might not know we've got some
service members in our immediate family
my son's a united states marine
and my unworthy son-in-law
is the united states navy pilot
currently deployed with the united
states navy
[Music]
they couldn't be with us tonight but i
couldn't be more proud that that navy
spouse my wonderful daughter
charlotte pence bond is traveling with
her mom and dad today would you say hi
to her
so proud of him but you deserve to know
when joe biden was vice president we
went through years of reckless
budget cuts didn't we john i mean that
hollowed out our military readiness
and over the last few days i read where
democrats in washington are already
saying that they're planning
they're planning massive cuts to our
national defense
to pay for their big government programs
president trump we rebuild our military
this president has signed the largest
investment in our national defense
since the days of ronald reagan and with
four more years
we're going to keep giving our soldiers
sailors airmen marines
and coast guard the resources and the
support they need
to defend our nation
and it's not just been about those who
serve in uniform it's been about those
of you who did serve
you know when joe biden was vice
president we remember the scandals at
the va that shocked the conscience of
the nation
don't we i mean we had veterans that
were literally dying
waiting for care at the va on waiting
lists
but when president trump came into the
oval office
those days are over our president has
signed the most sweeping reforms of the
va in 50
years we fired 3 000 va employees
who weren't giving our veterans the care
they deserve
the va now has a 91 percent
approval rating and veterans choice is
now available for every veteran in
america
and for our national defense to support
our veterans
for peace through strength it's just one
more
reason why we need a combat veteran
in the united states senate we need john
james
in the senate from the great state of
michigan
and when it comes to law and order
president donald trump has stood with
the men
and women who serve on the thin blue
line of law enforcement every
single day
i mean you all know what the president i
know the men and women who put on the
uniform of law enforcement in this
country
are some of the best people in america
and they deserve the respect of
every american every day
after the summer of violence that we've
seen after the rioting and looting that
we saw in philadelphia this week
the truth is joe biden would double down
on the policies that are leading
to violence in our cities now joe biden
says that america is
in his words systemically racist
he says that law enforcement has an
implicit bias
against minorities when joe biden was
asked whether he'd cut
funding for law enforcement he replied
yes
absolutely and his running mate kamala
harris recently praised the la mayor
for cutting 150 million out of the
lapd's budget
under president donald trump i'll make
your promise
we're not going to defund the police not
now not
ever we're gonna back the blue and we're
gonna back the blue for four more years
you know the president i know we don't
have to choose between supporting law
enforcement and supporting our
african-american neighbors and families
and other minorities in our cities we've
done both for the last three and a half
years and we're going to keep doing both
we're going to support law enforcement
with more resources and more training
and we're going to keep creating jobs
and opportunity
and educational choice options for
african americans and all the families
that live in our major cities
and we're going to have law and order
for every american of every race and
creed and color so help us god
all along the way under this president's
leadership we've stood for all
the liberties and freedoms enshrined in
our founding documents
like the freedom of religion the freedom
of speech
and president donald trump has stood
strong for the second amendment
right to keep and bear arms
we've appointed more than 220
conservative judges to our federal
courts at every level and i promise you
they're all conservatives who will
uphold the god-given liberties enshrined
in our constitution
like justice neil gorsuch justice brett
kavanaugh
and just like justice amy coney barrett
[Applause]
isn't she great didn't she great how
much did you like that when they asked
her what she had on that piece of paper
in front of them
nothing she's going to be an amazing
jurors for generations to come and she's
going to
she's going to make america proud but
you all deserve to know when joe biden
was vice president we saw a steady
assault
on our religious freedom we did they
used the power of the bureaucratic state
to erode the conscience rights of
doctors and nurses
they even hauled a group of catholic
nuns
into federal court to force them to
compromise their faith
to live under the mandates of obamacare
it's true
when judge amy coney barrett was up for
a different court two years ago
that same religious intolerance among
the democrats in washington came out
the leading democrat on the judiciary
committee
said she was concerned about judge
barrett's catholic faith
because she said and i quote the dogma
lives loudly within you
and hollywood elites started attacking
judge barrett and they've never stopped
well i got a message for the democrats
in washington
and their friends in hollywood
[Music]
[Applause]
false alarm
i got a message for the democrats in
washington and their friends in
hollywood
that dogma lives loudly in me
that dogma lives loudly in you
and the right to live and work and
worship according the dictates of our
faith
lives loudly in the constitution of the
united states of america
and under president donald trump we've
stood for that first freedom religious
freedom strong
we restored the conscience rights of
doctors and nurses and it was president
donald trump
who ended the assault on the little
sisters of the poor
and the supreme court made it permanent
and finally where joe biden and kamala
harris support taxpayer funding of
abortion
all the way up to the moment of earth i
couldn't be more proud
to be vice president to a president who
stands without apology for the sanctity
of human life
so in our first three years we rebuilt
our military we revived our economy
we stood for law and order liberties in
life
none of that would have been possible
without the strong support of michigan's
republicans in congress
so right after you reelect president
donald trump
right after you send john james to the
united states senate
[Applause]
we all need michigan to send congressman
jack bergman and congressman john
mulinar
to a new republican majority and retire
nancy pelosi
once and for all
[Applause]
out
i'm telling you
out
you know when you look at what we were
able to accomplish all of us with the
support of the people of michigan
that historic election four years ago
i think there's only one way you can
describe it in three
as president trump led our nation
through the worst global pandemic in a
century
and all along the way president donald
trump
put the health of america first
[Applause]
it's true before the first documented
case of community spread
president trump did what no american
president had ever done
in history he closed off all travel from
china the second largest economy in the
world
now joe biden at the time said that was
xenophobic which is i guess a fancy
word for racist he said closing off
travel during a global pandemic would
actually quote make things worse
but joe biden got it wrong and president
donald trump got it right
[Applause]
i can tell you as the head of the white
house coronavirus task force these last
eight months
president trump's action shutting off
travel to china
saved untold american lives because it
bought us
invaluable time to stand up the greatest
national mobilization
since world war ii
that's true we reinvented testing
we saw to the manufacturer in production
including here in michigan of billions
of supplies
of medical equipment and and ppe
we develop therapeutics that are saving
lives and we are literally a short time
away from having the first
safe coronavirus vaccine and tens of
millions of doses
for the american people
and i promise you the people of michigan
can be confident
we're going to keep making sure those
supplies are available for the great
doctors and nurses
we're going to keep protecting the
vulnerable we're going to keep saving
lives and distribute a vaccine
and we are opening up america again
[Applause]
it's amazing to think in the last five
months on that foundation we poured and
with the unprecedented
relief for families and businesses the
president is secured from congress
after losing 22 million jobs at the
height of this pandemic
we've already seen 11 and a half million
people go
back to work including 600 000 people
right here in michigan
we're opening up america and michigan is
roaring back
but you all deserve to know
joe biden is talking about shutting down
our economy again
it's true if you saw the newspapers the
last couple of days several european
countries are already talking about
shutting down
so you can bet that joe biden will lock
down the american economy if he makes it
to the white house
all the schools will be closed all your
churches synagogues places of worship
businesses will all be shuddered again i
mean right at the moment that
the american economy is getting back on
his feet
joe biden said this summer he would shut
it down
well joe biden says we're in for a long
dark winter
but under president donald trump
we're going to defeat the virus and the
best is yet to come
you know the choice in this election has
never been clear
the stakes have never been higher when
you look at their agenda
of higher taxes open borders socialized
medicine
a green new deal defunding the police
abortion on demand
it's clear and joe biden would be
nothing more than a trojan horse for the
radical left
i don't know if you've seen it in the
news but
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren are
already angling
for cabinet posts
you know joe biden said that democracy
is on the ballot tomorrow
well i think our economic recovery is on
the ballot
i think law and order are on the ballot
but i also think there are things far
more foundational to our country
that are on the ballot as well men and
women of michigan
in this election i think it's not going
to be so much whether america ends up
more republican or more democrat
more liberal or more conservative more
red or more blue
the choice in this election is whether
america remains america
whether we're going to chart a future
with president donald trump built on our
american heritage of faith
and family and patriotism
and freedom or whether we're going to
let joe biden
and the democratic party surrender our
country to the radical left
shut down our economy topple our
heritage
and our values and our freedom in an
avalanche of socialism and decline
so let me say from my heart to all of my
friends here in michigan
for all the ideals and values that have
always made this country unique
and exceptional for our very
freedom bequeathed to us by generations
of americans
we need to decide right here and right
now
that joe biden will never be president
of the united states we're going to
re-elect president donald trump
for four more years
ladies and gentlemen i've gotten to know
this president over the last four years
some people think we're a little bit
different
but actually we've gotten to be very
close friends
we spend time together every day or we
speak every day and i can tell you
president donald trump is the real deal
he's a man who says what he means and
means what he says
he never quits he never backs down
and he has never stopped fighting to
keep the promises
that he made to the american people now
it's our
turn to fight for him
it's our turn to fight for four more
years of president donald trump
in the white house
four more years means more jobs
four more years means more judges
four more years means more support for
our troops
and it's going to take at least four
more years
to train that swamp
[Applause]
so before he gets here i got a couple
things to ask you
number one before the polls close
tomorrow we need you to
vote michigan vote to reelect president
donald trump for four more years
[Applause]
time for speeches is almost over
time for voting is coming up tomorrow
morning i'm told the polls open
7 a.m open till 8 pm here in michigan
and remember
friends don't let friends vote alone
bring a family member
bring a neighbor bring a co-worker and
vote to re-elect
president donald trump to the white
house
and secondly after you vote with a
friend
i need you to go find somebody to talk
to about this election
i mean michigan always plays an outsized
role in presidential politics and
that'll be especially true this year
the choice that michigan makes is
literally going to be
a choice that sets our nation on one
path or another
for generations to come so you just need
to tell them about
the stakes in this election tell them
about the progress we made the way this
president's led us through this
challenging year the way we rebuild our
military revived our economy
the way america is coming back and tell
them about the choice
and tell them why you know the president
and i were on a
news show a week ago sunday
60 minutes it was
it was oh yeah yeah right so but there
was a great moment so the president got
asked a question
and i just his answer i'll just never
forget
the reporter looks at him and she says
thinking about all of you
she said so how would you describe your
supporters
and without hesitation the president
answered the question
she said how would you describe your
supporters and he said
they are people who love our country
so go find a neighbor tell them you love
america and tell them we need four more
years of president donald trump
in the white house
and finally i just encourage you and all
that remains between now and
when the polls close just to have faith
have faith in america
when you speak to your neighbors and
friends you know i think you study
american history every time the american
people have given a
clear choice between a future of more
freedom and less freedom they choose
freedom every time
have faith in the boundless capacity of
the american people to overcome any
challenge
and finally have faith that he who
planted
this miracle of democracy
on this wilderness shores will see us
through these challenging times
to bring us through stronger and better
than ever before
it's a verse that's been over the mantle
our home for 20 years since we
first stepped forward to serve in public
life
they're ancient words that americans
have long clung to and our little family
does
they simply say for i know the plans i
have for you
plans to prosper you not to harm you
plans to give you a hope and a future
have faith and pray for america
[Applause]
and i just know if all of us do all we
need to do between now and when the
polls close at eight o'clock
here in michigan tomorrow with your
continued support and your prayers
we're going to have a great victory all
across michigan and all across america
and with congressman jack bergman and
congressman john molinar in that new
republican majority
in the house
with john james in a larger
republican majority in the united states
senate
with president donald trump back in the
white house for four more years
and with god's help we're going to make
michigan and america
more prosperous than ever before we're
going to make michigan
and america safer than ever before
we're going to make michigan america
more united
than ever before
and with your support together
we will make america great again again
thank you all very much
god bless you god bless america now
let's go get it done michigan
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
staring
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
might be oh
everybody gets to dance
[Music]
oh
[Music]
right is to be an actress
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
only an american
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we
[Music]
to dance
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so many times it happens too
[Applause]
trade your fast for glory
don't lose your grip on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
is
[Music]
face the face
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
rising up straight to the top
of
[Music]
survived
[Music]
no survivors
[Music]
[Music]
tiger
[Music]
tiger
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
oh
oh yeah
[Music]
somehow i think you got to slow down
before you start
i think you're headed for a breakdown
so be careful not to show it
you really don't remember
all the voices in your head
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hurry up but you really don't remember
all the voices in your head
[Music]
[Music]
don't believe it's coming back soon
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that you may live
[Music]
is
[Music]
blue
do
[Music]
please please please
please
[Music]
please
[Music]
you did me wrong
[Music]
got me wrong
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
please
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i love you
[Music]
peace
[Music]
oh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president of the united states of
america
president donald j
[Music]
where trump least i know i'm free
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that right to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to venerate
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
[Music]
and defend her still today
[Music]
i know i'm free then i won't
forget the men who died who gave
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
god
thank you oh wow
this is a big crowd we have a lot of big
crowds but this is a big fan
this is great thank you very much
hello travers city hello michigan
we want the same result as we had
four years ago from michigan
and we fulfilled all our promises you
have auto plan
so many you didn't have one in 42 years
and now you have 17
and going up and they're going so fast i
don't know
nobody's complaining i can tell you that
but
we want that same result we're going to
get out and vote because
tomorrow we are going to win the state
and we are going to
win four four years in the white house
and i want to thank you to our great
vice president mike pence he worked so
hard
i will take him over kamala every day of
the week
i will take we will take mike he's great
he's great he's done a great job
he works very hard and he had a good
debate didn't he have a good debate
against kamala
from a different world with your vote we
will continue to cut your taxes
cut regulations support our police
support our great military protect our
second amendment
defend religious liberty and ensure more
products are proudly stamped
with that beautiful term made in the usa
[Applause]
right
next year will be the greatest economic
year in the history of our country you
know you had
a great year last year the year before
the year before three great years
the best you've ever had and you're
gonna have the best year you ever
had next year we're all set you saw what
happened under my leadership
our economy is now growing at the
fastest rate
ever ever ever recorded 33.1
you saw that on friday
[Music]
we created a record 11.4 million jobs in
the last five months that's a record
while foreign nations are in a free fall
sadly in a free fall you look at what's
happening with europe and
other places very sad we are creating an
economic powerhouse unrivaled anywhere
in the world you look at our numbers
look at the auto numbers look at what's
happening with
that business and so many other
businesses in this country but that
business because we happen to be in a
place that likes automobiles right
a recep gallup poll just came out
found that 56 percent of americans say
they
are better off today than they were four
years ago
under obama and biden
and that's during a pandemic and we're
rounding the corner we're rounding the
corner
and you've got to open your states
you've got to open your state open it
open it up governor open it up governor
right
open it up governor gotta open it up if
biden and harris
the radical left gain power they will
collapse our economy and send our nation
into a
very steep depression
they want to raise taxes at a level that
nobody's ever heard of before
biden will raise your taxes over four
trillion dollars
man it's not him do you think it's him
he doesn't have a clue
he has no clue but that's okay let's
assume he does we have to win
so that's it can't do that to our
country our country has too much
unbelievable potential actually
massively increasing your
regulations shutting down your economy
they're going to close down your
factories send your jobs overseas to
china and other places i don't think so
destroy the suburbs are you happy in the
suburbs that i
ended the regulation that was going to
destroy the suburbs that has been
destroyed this summer
[Music]
[Applause]
the women of the suburbs they love me i
think but you know the
fake news says they don't but i think
they do
[Music]
they love their home they love their
house
they don't want a development put next
to their house they want their house the
way it is
they want to have their beautiful house
and they want to have
security and they want to have safety i
think they like trump i really do that
happened the last time
that happened four years ago remember
they said women will not
vote for donald trump at that time
women will not and then at the end of
the evening where they're all crying
they say women what happened the women
came out right
well women the women liked us
that's nice well i like the women
and i will tell you i think the women
are great you notice we don't even talk
about the men with suburbia we let you
guys be alive
i want to dissolve your borders maybe
rip down the wall they were talking
about that let's take down the wall
you know we have our strongest border
right now and the wall is almost
complete
mexico is paying for the wall by the way
but it's almost complete
[Applause]
terminate religious liberty outlaw
private health care 180 million people
they want to take it away go to
socialized
medicine i don't think so you've worked
hard for that you have some of the
greatest health care in the world you've
worked hard for it they want to take it
away 180
million private plans take it away
now if you feel a little bad or if you
want to check up you go to a
hospital you wait online for about six
weeks and
you get yourself checked out if they say
you have a problem they can't do
anything about it that's called
socialized medicine
confiscate your guns second amendment
and indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lies
and just a little while ago on the
beautiful air force one how does it look
[Music]
by the way how about the sky
so beautiful let's just look at the sky
for a little while
i wish we had time right i wish we had
time
[Music]
so uh you know i've made would do five
today five of these
all with love all with big crowds all
with love
incredible
somebody said i actually do six today
because
we finished up last night in miami at 1
30 in the morning so
thank you oh thank you very much
that's good don't make me cry
don't make me cry you know if i started
to cry they'd have a big story they'd
say
the president broke down and cried
and i don't know if that's good for us
probably could
maybe it brings me up four or five
points i promise huh
i don't care but that's really nice you
know it's never been said before they
say that's never been
we've liked ronald reagan we've liked a
lot but they say that's
the love we love you think of it when
you think about it right
oh it's a it's an incredible it's an
incredible thing we've worked hard we've
gotten you everything we said we've done
the things we said we've done the things
we said we get you the biggest tax cut
in history the biggest regulation cut in
history
we've rebuilt our military our vets just
gave us a 91
approval rating on what we've had
we've got your space force and you'll be
making a lot of this stuff right here in
michigan space force is the first that
is the first time in 74 years since
air force think of that right a whole
new force i just signed an executive
order on air force one to teach our
students
pro-american values
it's a good thing with all the things
that i've been watching that have been
taking place over a
pretty long period of time a pretty long
period of time even before obama and
sleepy joe
biden has vowed to abolish the american
oil and natural gas industries and to
ban fracking look he said it
he said it he campaigned for over a year
we will ban fracking we will ban
fracking we will ban frankie then he
goes to pennsylvania
and they say well you know his people
told him
he didn't have any idea what that meant
but it was okay he listened so
they said listen you have to be in favor
of fracking now
he said okay no problem why i only said
it about 200 times during debates right
so they've been so now he goes into
pennsylvania where we just left
great people by the way you talk about
that was a
an unbelievably enthusiastic group of
people we're gonna win pennsylvania
we're gonna win
we're gonna win michigan too we're gonna
win
we're gonna win pennsylvania we won
pennsylvania last time too we won this
one we won
this one hadn't been won for many many
years and pennsylvania did the same
thing
it wouldn't but then trump came along
with one of them
we beat crooked hillary crook and
hillary
now we have a guy that makes hillary
look like a baby
no we had some we've had a good time
and until the chinese until the china
plague
came along everything was good we closed
it down we saved two million lives now
we're opening it up
we're the greatest economy we've ever
had see the hat
all the make america great again now
we're having it make america great again
again
you know and our country was coming
together you know the other side was
calling
everybody was successful best numbers
for unemployment african-american
hispanic-american
and by the way do you see what's going
on in florida
african-american the numbers are
phenomenal hispanic-american
the numbers are beyond belief
they got problems you notice they
haven't been talking too much about
florida for the last uh
six or seven hours they're not liking
what they see
they're not wow that is a lot of people
look you can't even see why don't you
take the cameras down there
you can't even see the end i hope you
can hear us down there
it's like two football fields away i
hope you can hear us
that's great well that's really good but
uh no florida's looking great
you're looking great came out two or
three up i don't know why two or three
up
you know am i supposed to be happy with
three up over this guy
i tell you but you know what let's just
put the win in the column we won't
even talk about it but you're looking
great north carolina great
uh iowa came out the big poll came out
yesterday you saw
and we were a lot up big big up well the
farmers like me you know
i got for the farmers 28 billion dollars
i got 28 billion from china thank you
very much
china thank you because they targeted
the farmers
they targeted the farmers and i said to
sonny perdue secretary of agriculture
sonny how much
he said well two years ago it was 12 and
last year was 16 billion
16 billion 12 billion a total of 28
billion and i tear off china we took the
28 billion we had a lot of money
left over into the treasury and we gave
it to the farmers and the farmers are
not complaining i'll tell you they're in
business
they would have been out of business
biden's energy ban
will send every state into crushing
poverty
and you know this you know what they're
doing from michigan to wisconsin
to arizona where we're leading very
nicely thank you
and to pennsylvania as long as i'm
president
we will remain the number one producer
of oil and natural gas
on earth and we
will remain energy independent we're
energy independent for the first time
first time that means we don't have to
call people up
in far away places and say we need some
oil please we'll send our armies over
there to
protect you and help you but we do have
great allies over there we'll help them
and
we've certainly helped israel but we
have a lot of good people over there
will help them
but we don't need their oil it's nice
not to need we have more oil than they
do now
you know we have actually more oil to do
we're the largest in the world isn't
that a nice feeling
[Applause]
sleepy joe and that would not have
happened except for what we've done over
the last three and a half years there's
never been an administration or
president
there's never been an administration
that has done
in the first three and a half years what
we've done never and not even twice
with all the things we've done
and the fake news never even questions
that i've been saying it for a long time
they don't even question it because they
can't
joe biden is a globalist who spent 47
years
outsourcing your job opening your
borders
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in endless ridiculous foreign wars
countries you never even heard of a vote
for biden is a vote to extinguish
and eradicate your state's auto industry
you don't like that do you i don't think
so
you know he was going to do the tpp he
was going to do
different things that would have been so
bad for you i ended it i ended it all
he was a cheerleader for nafta which was
the worst trade deal ever made probably
by any country
that sent all your auto jobs you know
they have 32 percent of our auto jobs
right
and uh it's probably the number one
reason i ran for president
and in fact i was in michigan i don't
know if anybody remembers this 12 years
ago they gave me the man of the year you
remember
and i had a big i made a speech and i
said why are you letting
you understand my business but i said
why are you letting them
steal your auto jobs they're all going
down to mexico and by the way plenty go
to canada too right
people don't know that and it was a
terrible thing that took place but we've
stopped that and now the usmca makes it
very very financially difficult
for them to do that it was very
important to me
and everybody said we'll never be able
to do it we'll never be able to
end nafta and you know why because it
was so good for canada and so good for
mexico and they have a lot of power
but we ended it and they're not that
happy but they're happy enough and we
have a great deal
and we have uh people i'll tell you
mexico we've had a great relationship
with mexico
canada is a little difficult to deal
with to be honest with you you know oh
canada
we all love oh canada right i love that
they stand for their national anthem and
we have to stand too
because you know
you know you saw the ratings from the
nba down 71
for their championship you know why
because people don't want to hear it
they don't want to hear it they want to
see a basketball game obviously not too
much
but i didn't watch it and a lot of
people didn't watch it and the nfl has
to be very careful they tried that game
two years ago and
i thought we taught them a lesson and
they have to be very careful
we have to respect our flag we have to
respect our anthem and we have to
respect our country
sleepy joe supported china's entry into
the wto
michigan lost half of all auto
manufacturing jobs
after those biden betrayals he also
supported the trans-pacific partnership
which would have been the death sentence
for the u.s auto industry
i cancelled tpp i ended the nafta
disaster and i took
the toughest action ever taken against
china we never took in 10 cents on china
i've taken in
billions and billions of dollars over
the last two years
joe biden is a corrupt politician they
don't want to write about it
they don't want to write about it
they're not allowed to write about it
their bosses whoever their bosses may be
they're not allowed to write about it
who sold out michigan to china
he sold you out that's one of the
reasons when they
send over a car they charge us 35
tax we charge them nothing but those
things changed we changed it
we changed
and it's going to change a lot more if
you give us another four years that i
can tell you
we were just beginning we were just
beginning
and not only with china with everyone
else that takes advantage of our country
[Applause]
thank you very much no but with
everybody else it takes
it's not only john it's everybody we
renegotiated the
south korea deal you know that that was
a deal crooked hillary made that deal it
was going to give 250 000 jobs she was
talking
this will produce 250 000 jobs
they signed it and she ended up being
correct but the 250 000 jobs all went to
south korea not to us
that was standard that was standard
biden is the living embodiment of the
decrepit and depraved political crash
that got rich bleeding
america dry and you know what happened
look there's there haven't been too many
states that have been affected like
you've been affected
you got seriously affected
that's what we're doing we're doing it
we're doing it but when i ran you never
told me it was going to be that deep
that vicious that rough
it's a deep sucker i thought would knock
it out fast
we went through three and a half years
of hell and here we are
and they're not too happy and they're
they're reeling
they're reeling they're going to be
knocked off very soon they're going to
be all knocked off
very soon
now we've done a good job but it was it
wasn't easy
you get impeached over a telephone call
that was perfect
perfect call a perfect call
congratulations on your victory ukraine
president ukraine nice man
never met him before congratulations sir
could you call up and congratulate the
president of
ukraine sure what happened oh he just
won okay good so i gave him a call
i avoided it for a long time because it
was a lot you know busy
call up and they say let's impeach him
i'll tell you
and we had great support from the
republican party i have to say that 197
to nothing in that
[Music]
52 and a half to one half you know the
half
that's right we had 52 and a half to one
half
mitt romney
[Music]
he still doesn't know why saying let's
see why did i do that
uh he wished he didn't do it i'll tell
you that
in 2016 michigan voted to fire
this corrupt political establishment and
you elected an outsider as president who
finally put
america first
and if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician i
probably wouldn't be here if i would
and if i don't always play by the rules
of washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fight harder
and harder and harder
and better than anyone's ever thought
for you
we we were brought here we were put here
to fight for you
i had a very easy life before this i
have to
thank you thank you
[Applause]
i had a very easy life i had a different
kind of a life
and you know what i wouldn't have
changed that decision when i said
first lady let's do it you're going to
be first lady she was actually one of
the people
she said are you sure you want to do
this first lady people love the first
lady they do
they love her she's good she's elegant
and she puts up with a lot from these
people you know it's like unbelievable
but she said uh but are you sure you
want to do this
i say i think i do yeah i think i do she
said you know you will win if you do
it you must be sure and i said you think
so i said you think so really she said
no you will win definitely but
the question is do you want to do it i
said yeah we do
we have to set this nation back on the
right course
no she said that i'll never forget that
was sort of cool you know you're
just like second nature you know you win
running against a lot of very talented
people
and then we had to run against a very
talented crooked machine
joe biden is bought and paid for by big
tech
big media and powerful special interests
you saw that over the last couple of
weeks
[Applause]
all the corruption and they refuse to
even talk about it could you imagine if
i got three and a half million from the
mayor of
moscow or one of my kids took three and
a half million from can you imagine that
and they refused to even discuss it they
don't want to discuss it
there is no proof they now say the
laptop from hell
was produced by russia this was shift
watermelon
right the laptop
was produced by russia and we say oh
no not again no
john ratcliffe came out immediately he's
great he's doing a great job he said it
was not produced by russia
but that's what they try to do they do
disinformation they're the biggest
disinformation group i'll tell you
they own him they control biden
and they know he will always do whatever
they want
they know that that's why they want him
i definitely don't do what they want
i definitely though
except they do one thing i get them good
ratings can you imagine if they don't
have
let's say they're head biden their
ratings will collapse every one of them
will be out of business they'll be out
of business so fast
every corrupt foreign won't be
it will be they will be out of business
so fast in fact i think they're going to
get together the new york times will die
the failing new york times washington
post which is basically a lobbyist for
bezos you know that
but they'll all get together and they'll
say listen we've made a big mistake here
we got to draft trump we got to get him
to run again this is no good
we're dying nobody cares can you imagine
that having viton we're going to put
something up can you imagine having
biden as your president
the biggest loser will be the fake news
media they will that will be so boring
you know their ratings are through the
roof everything's through the roof
the nfl is doing very badly you know why
everyone's watching politics because
they find politics to be much rougher
than the nfl it's much dirtier and more
disgusting and
and they don't change you know the nfl
they change the rules they make
everything like coming back
you can't touch anybody somebody tackles
too hard
they say 15-yard penalty and you're out
of the game and you're out for the
season you know the old days right
it was a little different but it's still
tough but this is much tougher
and people see it but you have to see
the ratings that's that's why the
ratings are bad for a lot of the sports
nobody ever thought of this but i
thought of it a couple of people wrote
it
the ratings are bad because so many
people are watching this it's
tougher it's true but they're going to
be calling for us please
please run again we think we're going to
endorse i got
endorsed by the pittsburgh
right pittsburgh post-gazette i gotta
endorse
first time since 1972
that they endorsed right that's a big
big newspaper very
good very liberal newspaper but that's
okay but
first time since 1972 that they endorsed
a republican so it's an honor and if you
don't read the first two or three
paragraphs it was one of the best
endorsements
yes we don't like him yes he has a
horrible personality but listen to this
it's not that i do but i have been under
siege
illegally for three and a half years
i've been fighting for three and a half
years and i said to somebody today
i wonder what it would be like if the
fake rusher hoax and all this crap with
the impeachment over nothing
over a phone call that was perfect that
was perfect
i wonder what it would be like if we
didn't have all of this horrible stuff
and and if it didn't you know we'd have
a very calm
a calm situation and maybe i'd be less
popular i don't know maybe i'd be less
popular
because you know what the fact is people
see that we fight we're fighting for you
but it's just
a really it's a really dirty horrible
business but i said
today because they were very they would
say
they don't like the personality and he's
always fighting i'm fighting
to survive you have to survive very few
people would have said
they would have been in the corner they
would have said mommy mommy put their
finger in their mouth put their thumb in
the mouth and say
mommy mommy take me home i'm outta here
get me the hell out of here
and say forget about the american people
mommy i want out of here right now
now we can't do that but you have to
fight hard and then you fight hard and
you hit them back and
then they say there's chaos in the white
house they caused the chaos we have a
great group of people we have a lot of
them here tonight
great people in the white house but it's
true i wonder why i wonder
if it would have been different you know
if they didn't because these were all
we caught them spying on our campaign
we caught them trying to take out a duly
elected
president of the united states that's
treason
that's treason we caught them
and someday maybe something's going to
be done about it too
you know maybe
[Applause]
oh boy oh boy oh boy i can't
we don't want to do anything prior to
the election well what about me
they did it they did it to me before
they spied on my campaign before the
election
we shouldn't do anything prior to the
election
and you know who we caught barack
hussein obama
and sleepy joe biden they were a part of
it
we ought to get these reports out they
should get them out before the election
as far as i'm concerned
i should get them out right before the
election
should have gotten them out a long time
ago we have we have information you
wouldn't even believe it i don't even
get involved i always said i'm going to
stay uninvolved
very hard for me to do i'll tell you no
it is because you know i didn't i didn't
have to do that
i thought it'd be the right thing and
yet they did the mueller report right
the phony mueller report
18 angry democrats smart 18
angry vicious many of them worked for
hillary clinton
18 angry democrats they spent 48 million
and at the end of two and a half years
no collusion
okay a friend of mine said you have to
be the most innocent man in the world
and they checked everything they check
taxes they check
for 48 million you check taxes right and
by the way
we announced you know i prepaid millions
and millions of dollars in taxes they
didn't say that
they refused to say they say well
pre-paying isn't paying i said no it's
pre-paid that's even worse
millions of dollars many millions of
dollars and that'll all come out
every correct and you know when you look
at it when you look at what's
going on seriously think of that just
think about that tonight when you're
with your family
i wonder if it would have been difficult
you know different i wonder if it would
have been
a different kind of a feel and you know
what honestly maybe it wouldn't have
been
as good maybe we wouldn't have these
massive graphs because you see
what somebody is where we're under siege
and you people get it
you're smarter than them you're smarter
than these people you get it and you've
always
and you've always gotten it it's a
beautiful thing and i'll never forget it
i want to tell you i'm never going to
forget it
but we were under siege and we caught
them
and it's treason or whatever you want to
call it
but with sleepy joe biden they don't
want to write anything we caught the
whole thing
the sun where's hunter where's hunter
the sun was like a human vacuum cleaner
he'd go in and follow his father let's
go to china today sean
they fly in on air force two right i
guarantee you one thing
mike pence i know his kids didn't do
that they don't do that they're
unbelievable kids
military but you know um let's go to
china today dad
i'd like to follow you it's like
[Music]
walks out with one and a half billion
dollars fees on
oh he must be a great investor you know
the greatest investors don't make that
deal with china china doesn't do that
they don't give money out for other
people that are less smart than them to
invest
let's give our money to somebody that's
not very smart to invest
okay that's a great idea he walked out
it only took him 10 minutes to get it to
1.5 billion dollars
that's millions of dollars in fees the
big one was the 10 million you saw that
one the letter
he wants 10 million a year for
introductory purposes okay 10 million
but it all blew up by that time the
laptop from hell was found
the one that ship said was developed in
russia
it's unbelievable and then you have
ukraine he goes into ukraine
his father was a judge of ukraine right
he was a judge of russia
ukraine china specifically
he goes into ukraine 180
3 000 a month do you have energy
experience it's an
energy right barista do you have energy
experience i know i don't i don't know
anything about energy well we'll pay you
183 000 a month
and we'll give you an upfront fee of
approximately 3 million would that be
satisfactory
no think of it no think of it and that's
and there are other things too other
kind then he's got the brother
and he's got a hall this is a corrupt
enterprise
and then they had the big band gets 10
the big man who's the big he's not a big
man to me to me he's a very
meek fragile he's a fragile person and
he's very agitated i watch him today
he gets more he gets more time on fox
i've never seen anybody on fox so much
him they have
everybody on fox they have all enemies
on fox i think it's crazy
but he gets a lot of time on fox but he
he's so agitated
and now he comes out with the aviator
glasses but they're a little too small
they should be
he wants to look like tom cruise from a
long time ago
no but he's fragile he's not going to be
there that's not what they're counting
when they're counting on somebody else
they're counting on by far the most
liberal person in
the senate kamala they like her
they liked him every corrupt force in
american life
that betrayed you and hurt you is
supporting
joe biden the failed establishment that
started the disastrous foreign wars they
support biden
the career politicians that offshored
your industries
and decimated your auto plants and you
suffered for many many years i'm telling
you that's why i'm here i think
primarily that was the first thing trade
i said how could they do that
they supported biden the open borders
lobbyists that killed our fellow
citizens with illegal drugs and gangs
and crime
that poured into our country they
support
biden they still do the anti-american
radicals
defaming our noble history heritage
and heroes they support
they support him they support sleepy joe
and you know
i signed a law that you take down any of
our statues
any of our monuments you go to jail for
10 years
it's amazing the way it seemed to have
stopped doesn't necessarily
mean somebody said oh it just stopped no
it didn't just stop
i took it old lord reactivated it
because the new law you go into this
with this bunch with nancy pelosi and
crying chuck schumer you know what
they'll do they'll give you a medal if
you rip down the statues
antifa and the rioters looters marxists
and left-wing extremists
they all support joe biden
this election comes down to a simple
choice do you want to be ruled by the
corrupt
and selfish political class or do you
want to be governed by
the american people yourselves you're
going to govern the way it was supposed
to be
a vote for biden is a vote to give
control of government over to the
globalists and the communist socialists
and wealthy
liberal hypocrites who want to silence
cancel
and punish you cancel culture they call
it cancel culture
no thank you we want to be proud of our
history good
bad whatever we want our history we want
to know and we want to learn from our
history
we don't want our history canceled we
want to learn there's things we have to
learn from our history too
if you want your children to be safe if
you want your
values to be respected if you want to be
treated with honor dignity and respect
then
i am asking you to go tomorrow and vote
for
a person named president trump
gotta win michigan
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a this is a big important place
we if we win michigan it's over
it's over we win the whole thing four
more years and then we can finish the
job we started so well
we can finish the job you know i get
nominated can you now i say it because
they don't write it
i just heard it i thought it was we got
four four
nobel peace prizes can you believe it
one for the middle east one for kosovo
serbia i mean
they want to make a trade deal they're
each fighting each other for many
decades they're fighting killing each
other
you've read i mean for years that you're
just automatic killing each other for
many many decades and
we're doing these trade deals with them
not big deals but they want them very
badly we're doing them
and they're each doing them and i said
to the people i said listen we're doing
deals they want to make the deal with us
everybody wants to make a deal with us
they said they're killing each other i
think right they're killing each other i
read about it they're killing each other
for decades
tell them we're not making a deal unless
they get together and make a peace
and we told that to them we're not
interested in doing deals unless you
guys can get along and
not kill each other you know it's human
life we don't know where it is
you don't know where it is some people
have never heard of the places but
they're places and they're people
they're human beings and i said
tell them we're going to do it but you
have to make peace and we got them
together we made peace
and they actually nominated me for nobel
peace prize i got four nominations and
four unrelated things that's crazy right
and i told the story you probably heard
about it the first one i went up
middle east you know the middle east is
coming along no blood in the sand no
nothing the middle east is great signed
already three countries we have seven
eight nine countries they could all sign
i said how did obama do it and they told
me he said good we'll do it the opposite
but not only obama for many many years
they haven't been able to do it and
we're gonna we literally i'd like to
finish that up too
we need a little more time you know we
need a little bit more time but we're
gonna we have countries
we have countries lined up no money and
no blood in the sand
no blood in this head remember what i
said four years ago i
am your voice and i will make america
great again and that's what we're doing
together we will defeat the corrupt
establishment
we will dethrone the failed political
class we will drain the washington swamp
and we will save the american dream for
your children for your grandchildren
this election is also a choice between a
deadly biden lockdown
or a safe vaccine the vaccine is coming
along great
couple of weeks a couple of weeks it's
going to be out soon
that ends the pandemic and it will end
anyway they hate it when i say
we're rounding the corner it's going to
end anyway but the vaccine will make it
go a lot quicker
and what we've done with therapeutics is
incredible excuse me here i am
but i like to say no no
i like to say it had no impact on me i
didn't really need it to just happen to
give it to me
because i'm a perfect physical specimen
that's very young
i'm very young and in perfect physical
shape
no but it's amazing what we've been able
to do is incredible
really incredible we will mass
distribute the vaccine in just a few
weeks and it will quickly eradicate this
virus we're going to start off very
much with you know we've learned about
it with our senior citizens especially
if they have
a condition a heart condition they have
some problem any kind of a problem boy
it's
it's vicious that's the ones that really
goes after but we're gonna protect our
great senior citizens first and then
it will go very quickly throughout for
anybody that wants it
won't be enforced it's not going to be
enforced
for people that want it and we'll get it
done and it'll it'll all take place
very quickly and by the way nobody else
would have been able to do what we did
you know nobody else would have been
able to do what we did you know joe
biden
he handled the swine flu as one of the
great catastrophes he was a
mess his own his own chief of staff said
we had no idea what the hell we were
doing i don't know why this guy admitted
that i still
i can't figure out why he admitted that
probably before joe thought he could
ever run you know joe thought his career
was over
because he wasn't thinking straight then
he ran
then he ran and elizabeth warren said i
want to stay until the end and take out
bernie you know she took out bernie
and we're running against joe instead of
bernie and bernie's going to run again
though in another four years
he's going to run again he one thing
about that guy he never gives up does he
but he's a hell of a loser i mean he
loses the first time
and he goes back he's like no hard
feelings he loses the second time
horribly the way they took
the democrats took advantage of bernie
sanders and everybody that he represents
and but they're looking to take over joe
they signed they you know they agreed to
the manifesto i call it you have to see
what's in that one
joe biden is promising to delay the
vaccine
and turn america into a prison state
that's what he wants
locking you in your home while letting
the far left rioters they can
so the riders and the looters the
anarchists antifa
they can go knock the hell out of your
your streets
set your stores on fire no problem
that's called protesting
we must protect our protesters but
you're not allowed to go to church
you're not allowed to have dinner right
the only one allowed to have dinner in
this state is the husband of your
governor
he's the only one that's got special
privileges
that was not a good day when he got
caught voting or whatever the hell are
we doing
who are you i'm the husband of the
governor
the police didn't go for that one too
well today huh
no that wasn't a great day now you got
to open up your state governor open it
up governor let the kids go back to
school
let the kids go back to school
it's like baron barron trump right they
said you know first lady had it i had it
they said sir you tested positive
first lady didn't come to see us a
little where they said sir
uh baron he just white house doctor
great doctor sean
sir barron just tested positive i said
test depositor for what
for corona you know it sounds like see i
like
the china virus or i like
the plague from china but a lot of
people use it like it sounds like an
island in
italy i said it's not corona but just
tested positive for
corona i said well i don't like that
that's not good baron he's you know he's
uh strong he's very tall he's only 14
years old he's very tall i can tell hi
bear
and he's a good boy but he just tested
positive and i said well
then about 12 minutes later i see the
doctor uh dr husband don't know it's
okay he's fine now he
took him about 12 seconds to get rid of
it
because they're young and they have a
strong immune system no he was
i mean he got better like it's so fast
and
you know what i say let the kids go to
school
[Applause]
and you're not going to hear that from
the other side they want to lock it up
the biden lockdown will mean no school
no graduations no weddings no
thanksgivings
no easter no christmas no fourth of july
no future for the youth
other than that it's going to be a great
life
now you got to let the kids go to school
get going
open up your state it's time and you
know we got to take care of our seniors
we have to take care of
people we understand it we have to do
things but
let the kids go back this is a lockdown
this is a shutdown
of course probably on a date like
november 4th
they'll announce well we're going to
decide to open up right did you see the
one
head of the union said yeah we want the
teachers to go back to work on november
4th that was not a good move
she announced we want the teachers to go
back on november 4th yeah i wonder why
that day
despite that we had the best numbers
look we have states that are locked down
closed down new york is having a hard
time i'll tell you they are
they are they don't know what the hell
they're doing great place i left it
three and a half years ago i loved it
and
it's very sad what's happening to new
york a very very sad thing in chicago
look at chicago
good seriously all run by democrats by
the way i want to just emphasize
how about portland with the anarchists
right with antifa and
they're antifa anarchists but how about
portland we could solve that problem in
25 minutes like we did
you know we went into seattle we were
ready to go in we're all set to go in
and we told them we're going in tomorrow
morning and the night before
they said okay well we're leaving now
that could have been done a long time
ago if they asked us we have to be asked
but and we did a great job in minnesota
we're going to win minnesota for two
reasons
we're going to win minnesota first time
since 1972
we're going to win minnesota you know
why number one is ilhan
omar the fact that she's there
no but she loves our country very much
right she has a great deep and abiding
love for our country
and the other one the hatred is just
crazy
how do we put up with this stuff right i
mean the hatred
but but she's number one reason and
maybe number two is the fact that
the national guard did one hell of a job
in minneapolis now they should have
called us
they should have called the week and a
half earlier it would have been nice you
wouldn't have had the fires raging
behind
the anchors that said this is a friendly
protester behind the anchor
the halls looked like the world was
burning down
this is a friendly protest because they
don't report the truth
a vote for biden is a vote for lockdowns
layoffs and misery you got to just
get out of this we have to we can't play
games our country has such
incredible potential we can't let this
happen
this country will never be a socialist
nation okay and that's what they want to
do
if you want a vaccine to kill the virus
a job to support your family
and freedom to live the great great life
that you've always want to have
then go cast your ballot tomorrow for
your all-time
favorite president i hope
and remember that secretary of defense
robert gates a respected guy he worked
with biden
he said biden has been wrong on nearly
every single major foreign policy and
national security issue
over the past four decades other than
that he spoke very well of him
but you don't have to believe me you
don't have to even listen to me
because it happens to be michigan we
spent a hell of a lot of money on that
right there
so roll the table
joe biden
[Music]
have you taken a cognitive no i haven't
taken the test
why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program you take
a test where you're taking cocaine or
not what do you think huh
are you a junkie by the way it's my
little sister valerie and i'm jill's
husband
oh no oh you switched on me this is my
wife this is my sister
they switched on me but i tell him if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black there is not a
single solitary reason in the world
why why as i said we shouldn't be in a
position
that everybody and that's my wife jill
hey jilly i'm jill's husband actually
and corn pop was a bad dude and he ran
a bunch of bad boys and i did yeah he
and back in those days you shot things
have changed play the radio make sure
the television
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night
the the phone make sure the kids hear
words
we hold these truths to be self-evident
all men and women created
by the go you know the you know the
thing because if you could
take care if you were a quartermaster
you can
sure in health take care of running a
you know department store
uh i think you know where in the second
floor of the ladies department you know
i mean well i'm sick and tired of smart
guys
you know the rapidly rising uh um
uh in with uh
with uh i don't know uh
there mendo caucus no you haven't you're
a lion dog face pony soldier
you're getting nervous man what kind of
country you're going to be
four more years of george georgia
he is going to find ourselves in a
position where
if uh trump gets elected uh we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be in a different
world
after lie after lie after lie
you know we have to come together that's
why i'm running
i'm running as a proud democrat for the
senate
and by the way you know i sit on the
stand and it gets hot i got a lot of i
got hairy legs
that turn that that that that that turn
uh um blonde in the sun and the kids
used to come up and reach into the pool
and rub my leg down so it was straight
and then watch the hair
come back up again they'd look at it so
i learned about roaches i learned about
kids jumping on my lap
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
barack and i think it's a right
for people that bad at care we have to
do at least several things one
we have to depend on what the
president's going to do right now
and first of all he has to uh tell
wait till the cases before anything
happens look
exacerbating the need for example firms
up environmental justice sorry as a bug
folks we got a lot of work to do i don't
need you to get me elected the case we
cannot let
this we've never allowed any crisis from
the civil war straight through to
the pandemic of 17 all the way around
16. we have never
never let our democracy say
second fiddle way that we can both have
a democracy and
elections and at the same time correct
the public health everywhere i've been
hearing all around the country
you're trying your best but it never
feels like enough
thanks and here comes the train that he
tried to make sure didn't continue to
run no that's the commuter
all right oh
that's what but folks look
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental filter
my physical as well as my mental fitness
i'll lead an effective strategy to
mobilize true
international pressure
[Applause]
can't let that happen you can't let that
happen
this country is so great we have such
potential we're just starting to show
our potential
if we didn't get hit with the plague
you'd see numbers but we're gonna do it
anyway
next year we're going to do it anyway
it's going to be incredible we can't let
that happen
everybody knows it and you know if you
were a nice guy he's never been a nice
guy he's never been a smart guy
never been smart everyone knows it never
been smart but if he was a nice guy we
wouldn't even do that but
that's just like a very small version
that's not even the bad stuff
and one thing i can tell you president
xi of china
putin kim jong-un
these guys are at the top of the game
they can't have this
well you don't want to give them this
we'll lose our country
we'll lose our country we can't do it we
can't do it binder would be a disaster
for
cherry growers farmers workers all
across your state you do so many
different things
joining us tonight our representative
jack bergman
[Applause]
two great guys jack thank you very much
and john
mullinar thank you john thank you fellas
great warriors they've been uh just
incredible people i'll tell you what
they've been with me through everything
right
and we appreciate it are you in good
shape with your races you don't need any
additional help
they're probably about 30 points up you
know when somebody's good they're good
you guys are great thank you very much
both and your next senator a tremendous
guy
i i spotted him a long time
[Applause]
i spotted him he was somebody i looked
there were
five people running a little while ago a
year ago for
a seat frankly you have somebody that's
okay
but i saw this man and i said
roll it back i want to see that again
john james right and i said well
what potential and then i found out west
point great student
great helicopter pilot i'd trust him 100
to pilot my helicopter i would do that
100 no he's supposed to be a great
a great warrior actually but i got him
to run and he got his feet a little wet
and then he
uh he just took off and i understand
you're doing very well in that poll
john i hear do you want to come up here
come on come here joe
come here come on
come on over he's a great guy and i hope
he's going to be
voted in you're doing very well come on
[Applause]
mr president it's an honor to have you
back in our state
are we grateful
are we grateful for the united states of
america
are we grateful for a president who's
been back in michigan
more in the past six days than gary
peters has in the past six years
you know it always tickles me a little
bit when career politicians talk about
what they're going to do
but joe biden has had four decades in
washington and gary peters has had three
decades in politics
and we still have a life that doesn't
benefit
all of us we need to get leadership
that's been tested in the real world
people who understand how to create jobs
in the real world
who can continue to bring results for
everyone
so it's my honor it's my honor as a war
fighter as a combat veteran
to stand before you here today and
encourage you to go vote
because only you can drain the swamp god
bless you
[Applause]
good guy great man
that's a big that's a big very important
vote you're casting in addition to
our vote john james he's a star he's
going to be a star
and you have somebody that's very
special and
you know his competition nobody knows
who the hell he is peters
you know you have a great state michigan
they say oh who's the senator peters
peters who the hell is peter's everyone
said
nobody knows who he is he's
uh he's a puppet for crying chuck
schumer i guess that's about it
anyway so good luck john james everyone
you have to do it
okay another great gentleman
house speaker lee chatfield
good nice to see you i hear you doing
good and a woman who is uh
like special to this part of the world
because she headed up our campaign
and you know sir she kept calling
calling please one more
visit because a republican hasn't won
michigan for many many years decades
long time
so she'd call please come over so i'd do
it didn't come over can i do it again
i came so much i felt like i should
become
a citizen of your state
that could happen that could happen but
you know she would just say one more
time so now it's toward the end
toward the end and i call and i said how
we doing she said you're gonna
maybe win but you have to do just one
more visit that's all
so i did one more i said i wished her
well and i said hey the elections in
three days and i want to just thank you
for working so hard thank you very much
i won't call you again
i got home and i got a phone call from
her she said you need one more time
right one more time and i came and we
ended up
right was that some time and we ended up
i started speaking
at one o'clock in the morning now it was
election day
and we had 32 000 people is that right
we had 32 000 people and i looked and i
said
it was one in the morning and you know
barack hussein obama
and hillary came and bill clinton came
and they all came the whole group and it
was an emergency because they heard they
were going to lose
and when they heard that rana called up
and she said you know if you came it
would be good because they're all coming
it's like an emergency
now their visit was at seven o'clock
which is prime time they had 500 people
i started speaking at one o'clock in the
morning we had 32
000. so it's now election day
and she just got me and she's she loves
your state i will tell you that and she
was so good i said
you know what we have to pick somebody
now to run the rnc
that's the republican national committee
it's a big deal
he said how about that woman from
michigan i mean
she just says herself and i'll tell you
she has done
a fantastic job ronna come on up here
come on up
come on
come on you want to talk here here come
here
[Applause]
thank you mr president hello michigan
lightning struck four years ago and we
blew the minds of the media
and the world when we delivered michigan
for president trump
are we ready for lightning to strike
twice
[Applause]
everyone get out of votes we need to
vote call your neighbors your friends
your family if you have wronged somebody
make it right
and get them to go vote let's make
america great again and re-elect
our fantastic president
[Applause]
she did a great job louie we all love
her we love her she's fantastic she's
got a spirit
like you wouldn't believe thank you
ronna very much and for the work and i
think we're going to have a fantastic
day it's going to be an incredible day
and
it's going to be uh you know i never
thought i'd say it but this
election is more important than 2016. i
never thought i'd say it
this is going to be because we can't
allow this to happen
to our country this will be the most
important election
in the history of our country it's going
to set a course it's going to go one way
or it's going to go another and if it
goes the other way it's going to be a
a terrible thing it's going to be a
terrible thing so get out there and vote
it's going to be we're going to we're
going to win this we're going to win it
we're winning
all over they have no idea what's going
on they have no idea
we see the real numbers and you know
it's no longer based on polling
we see what you know the early voting's
coming they're supposed to be way ahead
right in the early voting you know then
we catch them on election day i don't
know for whatever reason that's the way
it is we voted in election day
uh they're not way ahead
and they're having a lot of problems and
they have emergency calls out to people
it's going to be very interesting let's
do the
great red wave okay
and get that guy into john gentlemen we
need him
we need him in washington for decades
our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations fighting foreign wars
and defending foreign borders but now
we're finally protecting
our nation rebuilding our cities and we
are bringing
our jobs our factories and our troops
back home to the good old usa it's about
time
the troops are coming back they're
policemen we're serving as policemen all
over the world we're policemen now it's
not what
it's all about for 47 years joe biden
viciously attacked
black americans he called young black
men
super predators to every black american
i am asking you to go out and vote for
donald j
trump this is your one and only chance
to show
sleepy joe biden what you think of his
decision to attack you
to jail you and to betray you and
nobody's done it worse than him i'm
fighting for you
i got you criminal justice reform prison
reform
opportunity zones with tim scott great
guy
tim scott and funding for historically
black colleges
and universities which were treated
extremely badly
under my leadership we achieved so much
so much you know i said that and i made
the statement during the debate
nobody saw the debate last week did you
nobody
two weeks ago it was good good debate
but i said
nobody with perhaps the exception of
abraham lincoln a lot of people said
could you do the perhaps the exception
out please
has done more for the black community
than donald trump and that's true
president trump
all those things and more and that's
good and you know what it's showing up
too
when you look at florida take a look at
those numbers tomorrow they are
and hispanic do you see what's going on
with hispanic
hispanic numbers in florida they're
saying what's going on with hispanic
hispanic americans love trump and i love
them and i have for a long time
the black community is uh is
going to a level that nobody we haven't
seen in a long time it's been it's a
beautiful thing to watch and
they are saying what is going on this
could be something very interesting that
you're going to be watching
you're going to be watching some very
good television tomorrow night
very good television well you have to
say four years ago was that like the
most exciting evening in the history of
television
remember remember how it started this
would be a very short evening for donald
trump
this will be very easy very short and
then they say
donald trump has won the state of ohio
but it wasn't just that we won by eight
points oh by the way ohio's doing great
too
and it's donald trump has won the state
of florida
donald trump is one georgia he's won
south carolina
he's won their firewall north carolina
and he want to buy a lot
what's going on donald trump has just
won wisconsin he's just won
michigan
[Applause]
and they held pennsylvania even though
it was you know we only had it was 98
of the vote was that if i lost every
vote in the two percent
i still would have won by a lot they
they held it
so you and wisconsin got credit and
that's okay right
but i just told pennsylvania next time
you take credit so let's do it a little
bit earlier please
no we're going to we're going to do
fantastically in principle but that was
one of the most exciting evenings ever
and i
i think we're going to duplicate i don't
know can you ever surpass something like
that but
we're going to at least duplicate it and
we need it to carry on what we've been
doing we've brought so many jobs back
and
all of those plants that we talked about
we have plants you had nothing for 42
years
it just people leaving nobody coming and
now they're coming back and they're
coming back in droves and the numbers
are fantastic
under my leadership we achieved the most
secure
southern border in us history
the biden harris group
would increase refugees from terrorist
nations by over 700 percent
and that's the manifesto that was agreed
to with crazy burning
including from syria somalia and
yemen right you know that the biden
plan would overwhelm your communities
and turn michigan
minnesota wisconsin and the entire
midwest into a refugee camp
you're talking about tremendous amounts
of people coming into our country
we don't know who they are we don't know
anything about them
i'm protecting your families in keeping
radical
islamic terrorists the hell out of your
country if that's okay with music
if that's okay with michigan it's okay
with you
you know we put the ban on because we
want people to come into our country who
are going to love us
who are going to help us not people that
are going to hurt us
and blow up buildings we invested 2.5
trillion dollars in the u.s military the
largest
investment in the military we've ever
made we have to do it all made in the
usa a lot of it made
right here in your great state a lot of
it
and we now have the greatest equipment
anywhere in the world
fighter jets f-35s we have the best
tanks we have them as rockets and
bristles
we have the hydrosonic missile that goes
seven times faster right now than the
fastest missile in the world
if it went by us would say what was that
it would start over there and before you
could turn your head it would be over
there
i'll go seven times think of that seven
times faster it's incredible and we have
all of these things and our nuclear
arsenal now is
in tippy tap shape and you know what i
say
pray to god we never have to use it all
of it all of it
all of it we're making submarines the
likes of which nobody's ever seen before
we're doing it all and when i took over
it was depleted our military was
depleted we had old fighter jets
you had to go to the desert it was
called the graveyard for airplanes right
and you'd strip planes that were sitting
in the desert rotting in the desert
and you bring the parts back this was
what we were flying
in our airplanes now we have new tankers
we have the new
super fighters it's incredible what
we've done and it's much of it's already
here most of it
much of it's coming but it's all made in
our great country
we're also we were passed we just passed
the va choice and va accountability
and nobody thought that could be done
and we just got as i told you 91
approval from our vets our great vets we
obliterated
100 of the isis caliphate people don't
talk about that
when i took over it was a mess it was
all over the place we obliterated
we killed the leader of isis al baghdadi
and we eliminated the world's top
terrorists solomani is dead
i recognized the capital of israel and
opened the american embassy in jerusalem
i also recognized israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights they were working
on that
for 52 years and instead of
endless wars we're forging peace all
over the middle east they're all getting
together
they're all getting together a vote for
me and the republican party and john
james and everybody
it's a vote for the american dream
and in conclusion over the next four
years we will make america into the
manufacturing superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for
all that's already started we will hire
more police increased penalties for
assaults and law
enforcement and we will ban deadly
sanctuary cities with god's help we will
defend the right to life
religious liberty and keep
right you better get out there and vote
and we will defend keep and bear arms
you know keeping bear arms is called the
second amendment
which is under siege constantly that's
where we need john and everybody to help
us
and our great congressmen they've been
so great
and we appreciate it we will maintain
america's unrivaled military might and
we will ensure
peace through strength
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency lower drug prices
beyond any levels you've ever seen 60 70
80
i've instituted favorite nations that
drug companies do not like me
they do not like me they're taking out
more commercials i think than sleepy
jail
but we're going to get it down our
prices are the highest in the world for
many years
by far and we're bringing them down to
the lowest price anywhere in the world
matching the lowest price
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon in the united states will be the
first nation
to land an astronaut on mars
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our schools
and we will teach our children to love
our country honor our history
and always respect our great american
flag
[Music]
[Applause]
we will live by the timeless words of
our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
michigan
tomorrow you have the power with your
vote to save america you are going to
save america it's the most important
election i say it all the time
i play this is the most important
election our nation has ever had i
really believe that
never thought i would have said that in
a million years if you go back four
years
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers get
your boss and gregor
come on boy you got to get out and vote
get out and vote so important the red
wave i talk about it
the red wave i think is going to be far
bigger look at all of these
organic things that form in iowa and the
farm country attracted thousands and
thousands of tractors
yesterday didn't they have a hundred
miles of cars it was like a hundred
miles
all over the country four five six
thousand votes with trump trump and the
american flags all over
[Music]
never happened you know a movement like
this has never happened before it's
never happened
and we have to keep it going and finish
it out from midland to mackinac
from lansing to grand rapids and you
know where my last stop is going to be
i'm sorry to tell you that i feel a
little guilty
but grand rapids was where we did that
final great stop grand rapids and
so i'm going to be i'm going to be in
grand rapids it's going to be my last
stop
there's something nice about that
right because you can believe it so i've
done
i have five of these today and they're
all big monsters i had five of these
today
but i actually had six because yesterday
in miami
we left the stage at 1 30 in the morning
so somebody said if you want
they said so if you want you could say
you did six today i think i'm gonna say
that nobody else could do six of these
you think it's easy up here it's not
easy it's freezing up here too
i got the wind i can you don't have that
i have the wind i'm freezing my ass off
up here
only from michigan and from battle creek
and right here
in traverse city it's a good place right
good place
we inherit the legacy of american
patriots who gave their blood sweat and
tears
to defend our country and to defend our
freedom
we stand on the shoulders of american
heroes
who crossed the ocean settled the
continent tamed the wilderness
lay down the railroads right
raised up the great skyscrapers won two
world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and made america into the single
greatest nation
in the history of the world and the best
is yet
to come the best is yet to come
the best is yet to come and i mean that
proud citizens like you helped build
this country and together we are taking
back our country
we are returning power to you the
american people
with your help your devotion and your
drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning winning
[Applause]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of michigan we have made america
powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe
again and we will make
america great again thank you michigan
go out and vote thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
dough you can stay there and i'm sure
you will find
many ways to have a good time
it's fun to stay at the ymca
[Music]
it's fun
[Music]
you can do whatever you feel
[Music]
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure
[Music]
it's funny
someone came up to me
take a walk up the street
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so myself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you must have
and now she's in me
always
[Music]
[Music]
turning
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen don't leave yet the
vice president will be doing a live
interview with
martha mccallum on fox news right by the
stage she sings the songs
only you and you can't hear me
when i say
[Music]
me
[Music]
today
[Music]
is
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
is
music man
me
[Music]
i
[Music]
when i say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
on the highway
[Music]
is
[Music]
what
boom's been open for quite a while
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
right side
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
oh